he is the devourer of worlds and you
will know him by his hat how do you like
that intro a guy by the name of mr.
mashup made that I'd rather like that
I'm not sure how often I'll use it maybe
I'll reserve it for things were related
to MCU but we'll see I wanted to show it
off if nothing else so I decided I
wanted to talk about another character
that Marvel has recently reacquired
thanks to the purchase of Fox by Disney
and that is Galactus and some of my
thoughts about integrating him into the
MCU some maybe some do's and some don'ts
now I don't have as central a concept to
this like I did when I had my idea for
how to integrate magneto into the MCU
but I've still got a few things that I
want to throw out there I think it could
be fun and you know maybe I'll do this
with other characters if the response is
good so Galactus devourer of worlds with
an unending hunger for the life force of
planets and the things that live on them
if they happen to be inhabited big
cosmic figure usually a villain rights
were tied up in the Fantastic Four
that's who's usually associated with
most closely so bringing him in let's
start with my biggest do not and that is
do not make him the next big MCU wide
threat after Thanos that is too similar
and I don't mean that the characters are
similar in their motivation or their
trappings there are very different
characters but the scale and nature of
the conflict is too similar big powerful
dangerous devastating cosmic force comes
to earth that is going to be too similar
to Thanos
we can't just repeat that because people
will get bored Thanos has been well
built up too and people have been
waiting for this to happen if the next
big MCU wide threat is just a variant of
the same kind of thing you know what
people are gonna go oh well that's all
its gonna be from now okay
I'm done so first off you need to put
him on the back burner for a while which
will give you an opportunity to build to
him properly but you don't start with
him
you start with doom you do doom and have
dr. doom be your big MCU villain after
Thanos because he is powerful enough and
has a firm enough base of power that he
can be a thorn and basically everybody's
side that he can affect pretty much all
of the MCU except for guardians of the
galaxy who we don't need coming back all
the time anyways they're kind of off
doing their own thing but he is a good
way to have a big global threat that
feels very different from Thanos both in
terms of the nature of the character in
just the way that he operates so he
needs to be the next big threat after
Thanos why am I not just making a video
about doom largely because I think a lot
of how you approach doom is gonna be
dependent on how you choose to approach
the Fantastic Four and I don't have a
particularly firm idea on what you do
with the Fantastic Four and I I do think
Doom is too closely tied to that that
he's hard for me to try and talk about
in isolation if I have an idea maybe
I'll talk about it but right now let's
skip doom even though I think he should
be the next threat after Thanos so after
doom perhaps we can get to Galactus
first thing this is big he's got to be
the big guy in the helmet you cannot do
any version other than that no nanite
swarms no cosmic clouds no nothing it
has to be that what has been wonderful
about the mze MCU is that it has taken
things from the comics that we always
assume were way too goofy to ever work
on screen and made them work on screen
that is the bread and butter of this
franchise and they can definitely pull
this off for crying out loud
we had ego in guardians of the galaxy -
we saw the planet with a face we it was
only one shot that he looked like that
but we saw it they did it they can do
Galactus and not to mention that
help distinguish it from the awful weird
unsatisfying cloud they that was done in
the rise of the Silver Surfer whatever
the heck that second one was called back
in the early 2000s which of course then
brings me to the Silver Surfer who I'm
kind of inclined to scrap and here's why
I I will start by saying I have no
particular attachment to the Silver
Surfer I have nothing against him but
he's a character who I've always found
his role to be interesting but he is a
character never really did much for me I
mean III appreciate the backstory I get
they just kind of a tragic figure I get
all that but I I don't know guys he's
just kind of a blank slate and also
unfortunately was actually translated
pretty faithfully and decently even in
that Fantastic Four movie that I already
talked about and because he kind of
already does was done well pretty much
straight there isn't the same
opportunity for Marvel and the MCU to
just bring it back to basics and feel
like they're doing it justice for once
now it might still be possible to find a
way to get into work and give him a nice
pathos but it's just gonna it's just not
gonna feel as new or as fresh or as
necessary because like I said it was one
of the few aspects that wasn't awful in
that previous movie so Glac just does
still need a herald for my money I say
you put one of the minor players that
we've seen and some of the other cosmic
stuff in there may be like Roman day
from the Nova Corps in that first
Guardians movie john c reilly played him
and maybe you could even use that to set
up nova as its own movie either with him
or him assigning that mantle onto
somebody from Earth which is kind of
what happened in the comics nebulas
another possibility probably gonna
depend on what kind of state she's in
both as a character and if she's even
still alive at the end of infinity war
heck you could pull from Thor haven't
behind dollar Korg even if you wanted to
really kind of go outside the box that
said if you're not gonna pull a
character that we already know to be The
Herald okay fine do Silver Surfer the
build up
on him is also gonna be really important
because you get one of the few things
that the sort of ultimate in you Marvel
University it was build up to Galactus
very well like you have something that
was going on in this real big thing and
like what the heck is going on and then
this alien sort of technology you think
just as since I oh crap and I'm not
saying literally do that but we've got
off aliens kicking around at this point
they're gonna be introducing the scrolls
in a little bit you could have them
start to drop hints set things up heck
maybe the scrolls beyond Earth and the
first place is because he already ate
their home planet I think another thing
to do with Galactus just drop some hints
about some planets being gone destroyed
and not really make it clear why but
making but just give the hints that
there's something out there doing this
and build up to his eventual appearance
another thing that I think would be a
good idea to do with Galactus is to not
have him be a cackling style villain not
someone who's doing this like he does
this cuz it's what he has to do he
doesn't think particularly in it he
doesn't think about the impact he has on
a planet any more than most of us think
about where the hamburger were eating
came from yeah we have an awareness of
what it is but we're still gonna eat it
and that's pretty much the same for him
I think you could even emphasize the
loneliness of his existence that pretty
much his heralds all he's got cuz no
matter where he goes whether he's eating
a planet or not
nobody's happy to see him and I think
you could get a certain amount of
tragedy to a villain like that and again
it would be a nice way to contrast him
against villains who more sort of revel
in their badness like it looks like
Fanus is gonna be or I would expect doom
to be treated and another reason I say
build up to him is I think you should do
him as somebody bigger than just a
fantastic for villain especially in a
world where we've got the Avengers if a
planet devouring huge alien with a
massive helmet shows up I think it's
gonna ping more radars than just the
Fantastic Four
half the Fantastic Four because I assume
they'll be integrated by then have them
central to his being defeated
certainly but it shouldn't just be in
their movie it should be an Avengers
movie it should be a a big deal maybe
you could even get some other cosmic
villains involved in this
maybe Galactus already knows about all
the heroes that are on earth that make
it kind of a tough nut to crack but it's
so gonna say she ate his hunger he wants
to do it anyway maybe he enlists the
Beyonder to yank the heroes off stick
them on battleworld and keep them
occupied while he goes for the planet
maybe initially he's not even interested
in earth and he's actually here to claim
a new Herald which is a storyline that's
been done a couple times I think my
point is don't just give him an army of
faceless henchmen like the Chitauri like
the Ultron BOTS like I expect you will
probably have in the doom bots just find
a different way to occupy all the heroes
okay and finally if you take my advice
and go the more tragic route with them
don't kill him
like defeat him and find a way to deal
with them but don't don't kill him
because I also think he'd be a cool
thing to bring back I mean yeah that's
one of the things that's been really
neat about Galactus as the characters
sometimes when he shows up again you
know sometimes very far away from Earth
it's just like oh crap that's right he's
still out there he's not always even as
a villain it's just like this thing that
you have to watch out for and
occasionally you stumble across me oh
yeah
book it the other way and I I would kind
of like to see him be that so those are
some of my rambling not particularly
focused not built around a central
concept notions on Galactus and things
to do or avoid doing in terms of
integrating him into the MCU those are
my thoughts what are yours whatever they
are drop something down to comments
let's talk about it do all those things
there's likes and subscribes I have a
podcast and a Twitter and an email all
that stuff's down below until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]